we'll use this to segue into the this
this the hit piece
and how the fake news operates amazing
story amazing story tell me the story
james oh my goodness well i've done
i don't think you've ever seen me as
angry and passionate that week i did
those response videos i was angry i'm i
was pissed
i don't get angry i was angry at i was
upset
i've never seen anything like this in my
career we put out this minnesota video
and it's got this guy in the car with
all the ballots and this was recorded
on his snapchat i did not secretly
record him now you might ask
this is a private snapchat that one of
my sources obtained so he
he he posted to an individual or two and
that person
sent it to me it is has a timestamp on
the snapchats it's july 2nd
so we didn't even record this tim it was
recorded by himself
of himself in his car with many many
many absentee ballots it's illegal in
minnesota to have more than three
we put this out all these clips of
people saying we're breaking the law we
don't care
all these somalis doing cash
transactions for ballots it's all on the
tape
and the new york times puts out an
article tim two hours before the
presidential debate because i'm pretty
sure trump was going to mention this he
all you know he's talking about fraud
battlefront
and it says you know videos are part of
a coordinated disinformation uh campaign
experts say who are these experts are
they
stanford university researchers who they
paid so what's interesting about this
and this is something that you know
again going back to the soviet union
they tend to project
onto me that which they are they
are the thing that they hate and they
accuse me of doing the thing that they
do and they do it first and they do it
well
and it's an incredibly effective
machiavellian tactic so they come out
and say it's a coordinate disinformation
campaign
well that's precisely what the new york
times is doing and i'm going to
speculate
i think the executive out of the new
york times knew that was defamatory and
it is and i would win on summary
judgment if i sue them and i'm about to
but they told me they're going to
retract the article so
we'll see if they retract in the coming
days and if they don't i'll sue them for
defamation
well so so that that pulls the teeth out
of any suit the fact that they said oh
yeah we're going to retract yeah the
general counsel said that they're going
to make a correction so that but
the usa today has already used the
article so the usa today's entrepreneur
attraction
so walk us through that though so let's
get to that point well let me just
finish the point about so
so i threatened to suit for defamation
the new york times
um and they they basically uh say that
it's a disinformation campaign the new
york times
i think they made a utilitarian calculus
and said we know this is defamatory but
we need to
muddy the waters of o'keeffe's work
three three weeks before the election
and we'll just deal with it two years
from now in a trial
and they knew they knew that they were
part
they are part of their own
disinformation campaign
and it's a genius to call me a
disinformation expert
they're the ones engaging in
disinformation by contacting stanford
quoting some idiot in a room who says
it's probably disinformation
it is literally i've never been more
pissed so anyways here's what happens
we put a video out usa today quotes the
new york times
facebook views usa today as credible and
sends a notification out to every single
person who has ever shared that
minnesota video i got text from everyone
in the country
james facebook just told me your fake
news and i think we've got
my attorney says and i and i don't want
to be in the litigation business tim
because there's only so many people i
can sue
my general counsel told me today is like
what about sue and you're suing facebook
i mean it's just the only thing these
people respond to is raw
power that's what they want they only
care the only thing they respond to
is is a threat to their power and i have
not and this is a pretty extraordinary
accomplishment i don't mean to brag
project veritas corporation has never
lost a lawsuit not once
we've been sued over a dozen times we've
won eight straight lawsuits why
because i'll take it all the way to the
supreme court at the end of the day i'm
in the right
the facts and law on our side so a
similar thing happened to me
someone took a tweet of mine that was
factually correct about
bill clinton epstein island and then
reposted the screenshot facebook said it
was fake news
facebook's liaison for politics told me
they can't do anything about it
because it's the organizations that post
the fact check
the fact-checking organization told me
to basically shove it even though they
knew what i posted was true
they have the power to deem it fake news
even though the link they put on it
confirmed everything i said
which made me think no facebook's the
one who published that
when when facebook sends a notification
to your followers
or to people who have shared the story
that you are fake news
that's facebook making a statement i
think you should sue facebook
yes it's just i think you should
challenge their section 230 protections
under the
under the rules that they are not fairly
moderating and
they personally made facebook made a
defamatory statement
in that presumably algorithmic response
this is a very important point you're
making and i want your audience to know
that it's very important we fight back
you know it isn't it is a it is a pain
in the butt but you have to i have to
sue these people
and i will say the new york times if
they don't retract the article i'm suing
them i swear
it's going to happen and i have to go
through discovery they'll go through
discovery it's a it's very
labor-intensive it's a headache i went
to a trial once a jury trial it's
you're putting your company on the line
but you have to fight back against these
people in the courts
and there's a lot of federal judges out
there who do believe in the rule of law
you can't defame someone you can't
you can't intentionally maliciously you
know if you're a public figure like me
or tim
it's it's a actual malice you have to
prove that they knew that they lied
yep that's hard and it's hard to prove
and and but i think we went on summary
judgment after discovery against the new
york times and nick sandman sued the new
york times and cnn
he settled out of court would you get
them to downscale the value of usa today
as a fact-checking organization
uh i don't know how i could do that uh
uh
what do you mean by downscale well if
usa today came out and said that what
you did was fake news
and they were wrong that's that they're
never can you force facebook
through litigation to discredit usa
today henceforth
it's a it's a war of attrition i mean
you're fighting
all these litigation battles but usa
today is going to have to print a
correction
because the new york times is gonna have
to print a correction and when that
happens we can go to facebook
but the problem is while all this is
happening we're two weeks away from a
presidential election i continue
breaking videos
and and media establishments no no it's
a disinformation campaign according to
new york times
yeah so you have to as an entrepreneur
i've had to build a whole division
within project veritas you just fire
legal letters off to publications every
day we have like two people doing that
every single day now
for people that want to start an
organization like very hard
how would they do it so walk me through
how did you start the organization
and how did you build it out i mean the
bit
as they say in in economics the barriers
to entry are two
the only other person that i know of
that has tried to do this and was very
effective is david deliden
center for medical progress he did the
planned parenthood baby harvesting
videos
and he was instantly sued by everyone
kamala harris is it kamala
or kamala i don't know what is it like
i don't want to get that wrong yeah
kamala harris
then attorney general of california
raided his home you know took his drives
and and they just
so i'm a teen fellaini i i gotta i gotta
jump in on this
you've got a successful organization
you're you're bringing in money from
donors you're getting millions and
millions of views
you know you're breaking these huge
stories that i think what you got like
eight million views or what was it the
last
yeah the minnesota thing was like 20
million on twitter one video is 20
million or something
so what's a regular person going to do i
mean look
when i got defamed by the today you know
the today show put a picture of my face
up on tv and claimed i was a conspiracy
theorist
and it was totally the what they accused
me of was made up entirely
and i couldn't do anything about it yeah
just they just they can lie and they can
get away with it
i don't have the ability to go up
against nbc universal which
was that comcast like multi-billion
dollar international corporation
well and this you know dan borsten this
is the quote we use at project garatosh
to answer your question what can i do
you're going back to what can i do
question which i think is the most
important question in the world
in this world of illusion and quasi
illusion our heroes tend to be anonymous
so school teachers
janitors cops just honest decent salt of
the earth people
and most of them aren't are just
drinking their coffee going to work
don't mess my life
but there's like point one or point zero
one percent of the people that say you
know what
screw it i don't know you know there are
some things more important in life than
than
than than bread there are just things
that are more eternal
so i don't know if many people can you
can contribute one dollar to project
veritas i suppose that could be
something you could do but you know i
think there's a for tim there is a tiny
fraction of people
that are willing to make the ultimate
sacrifice for a cause greater than
themselves
and this big the greatest sacrifice
right now in this world appears to be
giving up your reputation and and and
that is
a sacrifice that few people are willing
to give up and there are people wanting
to do that and that's what they can do
well i guess what i mean is if john
doe plumber in minnesota gets defamed by
the new york times what's he going to do
about it
i mean granted public figures have
different standards this regular guy
can you know have an easier go of it for
defamation but there are smaller public
figures you know when nick sandman
was smeared across the board they
actually argued he was an involuntary
public figure meaning they can put a
camera in your face
and then claim you're a public figure
and that's their defense granted there
needs to be more
organizational entrepreneurs like you
like others like you someone needs to
start an organization
raising money suing the new york times
for defaming ordinary citizens
i can't do that i'm only one man i work
110 hours a week
if i work anymore i'll get sick and die
someone there needs to be more people
with
i'm just going to say people with balls
and and and there just has to be
more people that that do this sort of
thing i can't do all of it
i encourage other people to start
organizations and have balls
and just do what's right that is there
is a great idea start an organization
and sue the new york times for defaming
ordinary citizens and by the way
you'll raise 50 million oh yeah for sure
easy done
no you i i probably do another life you
know now they're but now they're going
to be
like that's that's trying to destroy no
journalism no no no it is
it is it is i mean there are
philosophical and constitutional
arguments against defamation in this
country
you can't just maliciously lie about
someone they do it every day
and well yeah but there are a nation of
laws
and in the federal court system you can
win in the federal court system in this
country i mean trump appointed like i
don't know how many
200 federal judges they'll be there
they're con they're article 3
constitutionally appointed federal
judges who believe in the rule of law
i took it all the way to a jury verdict
in this case in north carolina with this
democracy partners individual who sued
me for quoting
quoting her wow i quoted a guy
talking about this woman the woman sues
me i'm like why the hell you suing me
he's the one who said it
and i quoted him and it got all the way
to a jury verdict
a jury verdict there's an incredible
documentary on youtube about this
we produced it and it gets all the way
the jury is coming out of the box they
sit down
i can't believe them there's a jury
about to issue a verdict multi-million
dollar defamation case
and the federal judge guy named what was
his name
uh last name federal judge in north
carolina
he says stop stop it and he pulls out a
rare
rule 50 in federal court directed
vertically case dismissed
wow and he says this is outrageous if
mike wallace were being sued
people would laugh those are his words
and he said o'keefe was just quoting
they're just
quoting the guy yeah why did it get that
far it got that far because of my brand
i
edit videos when you actually
deconstruct all the bs
and you actually take it all the way to
a jury and to an appeals court
there's still some semblance of the rule
of law in this country and people need
to sue
media corporations and and they have to
go all the way it's expensive though man
well
like i said have some guy like you start
a company with the soul
our mission center make me do it not you
but someone someone
if it were a different life maybe i can
clone myself
and you know it's and it's a project you
know sue the new york times
you will raise 50 you will raise 50
million dollars and you'll have so much
business
project to sue the new york times i love
it it's very on the nose so like a
non-profit that raises money to help
c3 511c tax deductible donations with a
stated mission to expose fraud and
hypocrisy how about
the citizens defamation defense fund
that's all right
what is that cddf yes that sounds too
much washington dc
you know get them yeah that sounds so
awesome it sounds like an organization
doesn't do anything how about the
citizens retribution center
yes i like it that's better defamatory
retribution
legion you could raise millions crc
i mean if the southern poverty law
center can raise 500 mil
i'm sure store it all what in the
bahamas or something yeah but you got to
have balls you got to stand up
there were many times i'll give you one
quick story anecdote from that north
carolina
case where they put me in a room with
this you know these plaintiffs the
people sue me and they have an
arbitration here you know they try to
negotiate
and the judge comes in there and he goes
now okay if you could lose you could
lose your company you could risk it all
why don't you just give this person you
know
you know 25 thousand dollars in call
you're going to spend a million dollars
okay just give her 25.
and i said something to the effect of so
help me god i will not settle this
lawsuit
so they try to do is threaten you and
scare you and all this crap
and i just said you know what if i have
to go bankrupt if i have to give it all
away if i have to liquidate the close in
my watch
and go bankrupt i have to going to risk
everything in order to stand on
principle
you have to be willing to do that if you
want to play in this game
if you if you are going to give them an
inch or sacrifice your principles or
sell out
or fear anyone don't even start it i
forget it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you